the judges he blocked any of their shots
I wouldn't leave I was scottie pippen Rd
wait I wouldn't give on low score
thirty-four-year-old
sex ed I can't say this why
[Music]
can I say it
if the man has a cape on and then a so
we're going to go conch a call the
gospel to call we can't say Superman
from the building
[Applause]
he should jump over you over you
let's go bro ladies each other let's go
boy see girl stepping out the pool
putting on the Cape putting on the
Atlantis chest - white Howard now it's
[ __ ] it and I will let you know
[Music]
[Applause]
Superman was close but it wasn't the
Superman in the building right but it
was still a nice dunk it's still at 8 I
do like it Jimmy really you know old
school
I mean he's still jumping for years that
is that is still impressive he could
have taken on further and threw it in
like he did before but he wanted to make
it with the Cape flying the blue shirt
the 24 Saturday yesterday hey I got a I
got a peer pressured into this courtyard
are we having another Chicago
conspiracies
we have news
are we havin another conspiracy
freshness he wanted to do something and
out there happy with it